And now it's the old scout master.
Hey, I'm back again. Yeah, I know it took a little while, Sorry about that, Doing my best
to pay attention to what's going on at ScoutMasterCGcom. I sure appreciate your emails and things
like that. Like my father would say, this is better than a poke in the eye with a sharp
stick. I mean, most things are right. Hey, this is podcast number 361..
Welcome back to the ScoutMaster podcast. This is Clark Green and and finally, yes,
we're back with the promised series of talks about what scouting is, kind of
foundational series of talks. It's gonna go for four or five podcasts and I'm going
to need your help and I'll remind you of this later in the podcast. I need you
to reply to these podcasts and ask me questions. Let me know if I am effectively
communicating. I am asking you for your reflections, your ideas, your questions
about this podcast. You can get in touch with me very easily. Go to scoutmastercgcom,
Click the contact link at the top of the page, or you can get in touch with
me at Clark at scoutmastercgcom. C-L-A-R-K-E at scoutmastercgcom. My attempt in the
next several podcasts is going to be to explain what I understand about the
basics of scouting and to build on a foundation of ideas that should help
you be a better scouter. It's my theory that having these basic ideas in your
head and understanding the way that the whole process works is how you figure
out what practical things you should be doing or what you shouldn't be doing.
So if you've come to this podcast looking for quickly actionable things like
program ideas and methods and stuff like that, you're probably not going to
find it here, because there are plenty of resources that I've created that you
can find at scoutmastercgcom and you can find on any number of other
places online And in books and other materials that have been produced for
over a century of scouting. there's just this wealth of practical, quickly
actionable things out there, But they're not really all that useful. without
knowing why you're doing this and how the whole process works,
These podcasts are going to tend to be much shorter than one would expect.
If I've done my work of distilling these ideas down, it shouldn't take that long
to explain them. So that's what I'm going to do,
And then we're going to follow up with your questions, ideas,
reflections in the next podcast. So, with all that in mind, let's get started,
shall we
Scout?
I think ideally when we get started on something like this. what would be
best if we started with a totally clean slate And you didn't have any
presumptions about what scouting is or how it works. Now, that is an
impossibility, isn't it? Because everybody understands something
about scouting. So what I want to ask you to do is just kind of open
your mind and lay aside what you think scouting is and follow along
with me as we start with a blank slate and build on basic ideas.
So I'm going to employ a big analogy here for this entire series.
That's the best way that I've figured out how to do this. It's a big
analogy. Analogies are great because they take something that is
familiar to us and explain something that is unfamiliar. But
let's remember that analogies break down at some point. We
can't push them, because an analogy is not the thing that it is
set out to describe. So if I say A is like B, that doesn't mean
that A is B. So just kind of keep that in mind because, as I said,
analogies break down. So now that you have that, you have that
warning, let's go. The analogy I want to apply to scouting is
that scouting is a game. I'm not the originator of that
analogy, The founder of scouting. Robert Baden Powell is the first
person to talk about scouting in that way, And it would be a good
idea for us to go back and to look at the early history of
scouting, not out of nostalgia for it but just as a way of
understanding how it functions and how it works. So here's a
lightning review, okay, of the way scouting started. Robert
Baden Powell was a noted British Army officer, famous in Great
Britain for a campaign called the Siege of Motha King during the
Boer War. So that's in the late 1800s. Baden Powell employed
some unique military strategy during the siege that he wrote
about in his book AIDS to Scouting in 1899. AIDS to Scouting
became unexpectedly popular with people working with youth in
Great Britain. Baden Powell saw this. he was encouraged to write
a book specifically for young people, And so Scouting for
Boys was published in 1908.. Baden Powell openly depended on many
of the ideas in a book called The Birch Bark Role of the
Woodcraft Indians, published in 1906 by Ernest Thompson Seton,
who would go on to be one of the founders of the Boy Scouts
of America. But when Scouting for Boys was published, there was
no organization. there was not. Baden Powell didn't start an
organization, He published a book. That book got into the
hands of young people in Great Britain, boys and girls- and
they started their own scouting adventures. They formed
patrols and started doing what was in the book. Adult
involvement and organizations came later. Now, all of that
history is helpful to know because it helps you form a
concept of this game that we're playing. The game came
first. Everything else came later. Very much like when, in
1891,, Dr James Naismith nailed a peach basket up on the
wall in Springfield, Massachusetts. There was no
league, There was no NBA, There was just the idea of
this form of the game that we know now as basketball.
So the game existed before all of these formal things. It's
important to understand that about scouting, because the
elements of the game are the most important thing, Not all
the things that have been created around to contain the
elements of the game. So our analogy is: scouting is first
and foremost a game that's played by young people and
it can be done without any kind of organizational
support. Fortunately, we have organizational support, but
the organization is not the game. As we go through this
series, we're going to talk about what's important and
what's not. What's important is understanding the game
and helping young people play it, That's all. A game has a
set of rules, and rules are important because they
define the game. So scouting has sets of rules and
policies and procedures created by the organizations that
contain scouting. You're the member of such an
organization. You should understand the rules,
policies and procedures of that organization and as a
scouter, you're honor bound to follow them. It takes a
certain kind of person to be a scouter, Let's let's face
it, and often that certain kind of person is not all
that interested in being told what to do by some
organization somewhere. but no matter what the
organization, if you look at their rules, policies
and procedures and you understand the basics of
the game, the rules, policies and procedures
begin to make a lot more sense. So I am not
disdainful of these bigger organizations and I
encourage you not to be. I encourage you to look for
the support that they offer, enabling you and your
scouts to play the game of scouting. So at this
point we know that scouting is a game and that
that game is defined by rules, policies and
procedures that are presented by the
organization that you're a part of. but it's also
defined by those very things that were present
when the game began and we're going to call those
the strategies and methods, the locations and the
skills of the game and the goal of the game. So
let's start by talking about the strategies and
methods, which are different than the rules.
and here's one big thing that I think gets
confused when we go to train scouts is that
we take the strategies and methods, the rules,
policies and procedures, we mix them all together
and we present that as a way to be trained in this
thing called scouting, and it doesn't work all that
well because, while they're interdependent,
they're not easily understood when they're all mixed up.
So we need to be more theoretical when we're
talking about the strategies and methods that we apply.
The rules, policies and procedures are
limitations and definitions. Strategies and methods
are more open and interesting. Before we go any further, we have to
understand that we've reached a point where our analogy breaks down,
because in games you have a competition,
which teams or individuals are in competition with each other.
In scouting, we don't have competitions with other individuals. What we have is
a challenge to achieve personal goals rather than
competition between individuals or teams.
Yes, we may have competitions between individuals and teams, but
they are not the goal of the game. They're a method employed in playing the
game. So what are our strategies and methods? Well,
you're probably familiar with a list of strategies or methods,
and there are a list of eight, there are a list of 10, there are a list of 12..
There is one key method or strategy that we employ in scouting and we
typically call that the patrol method, but the word patrol
is a bit of a stumbling block in understanding what we're talking
about. So let's call it the small group method,
because the scouting game is played in small groups.
In a scout troop it's a patrol, in a cub pack it's a den,
but you get the idea. It's a small group. I would say that probably most
people don't think of it in those terms,
but that is the key method, and the reason that it's key
is because scouting works on that small group basis.
That's where we really advance towards the goal.
So what is our goal? Well, our goal is not to score more points than the
opposing team or individual. It's not to rack up a bunch of
individual achievements. Our goal is quite intriguing because
when Baden Powell founded scouting, he founded it
based on the idea that it would develop a set of ideals. in scouts,
Those ideals are embodied by the scout, oath and law,
which are expressions of things that have been at the forefront of every
enlightened human endeavor throughout history, and the development of those
ideals in individual scouts is our goal.
We'll talk about that more in depth as we go along,
but for now that's the important point. Games also have a location, and this is
this is where the analogy works pretty well, but not exactly well,
because the location that we play the game of scouting in
is the outdoors, and that is more important than it might appear
at first blush. but we play our game of scouting
in the out of doors. Games have sets of skills and scouting has a set of skills.
Every game involves skills. you have to dribble a basketball, you have to be able
to swing a bat and hit a baseball and you have to be able to put
accurately playing the game of golf. You take any of those skills in
isolation and they don't have a whole lot of practicality
outside of the construct of the game, but the discipline of mind and body
that you apply in learning them in the game
applies outside of the game. Scouting is the same way,
kind of, because some of the skills in scouting
don't have tremendous practical application outside of the game. some of
them certainly do, but, like a free throw, a home run
or sinking a 20-foot putt, mastery of those skills
is not the most important thing. the idea is the process
that you went through to master those skills
can be applied to many other areas of life, and
the same is true with scouting, even though some of the skills are very
applicable outside of the construct of the game. so let's go back
and review this for a moment. we're using the analogy that scouting is a game.
it, within that analogy, it shares the components of
most of the other games we're familiar with. it has sets of rules and
policies and procedures, it has strategies or methods,
it has a location, it has skills and it has an ultimate goal.
I want you to think about this particular phrase.
scouting is the development of character
in individual scouts, achieved by applying the patrol method.
I kind of have this fascination with trying to
boil things down to one sentence. that's my one sentence.
the game of scouting is a development of character with individual scouts by
applying the patrol method, and I think that will be
oft repeated as we move forward in these foundational talks:
the game of scouting and the other games that we've talked about.
there is something about them that has this kind of internal
conflict because they are theoretically perfectible
things. there is a theoretical perfect basketball game.
there's a theoretical perfect baseball game.
there's a theoretical perfect round of golf,
but they're only perfectible in theory.
to my knowledge, the only game that has ever achieved
theoretical perfection is bowling, where you can
actually roll a perfect game. there are aspects of the other games that
you know where you have a no-hitter or something like that
that I guess you could argue are expressions of perfection.
but when we construct games we have this idea of perfection of the game
that is theoretically attainable but is practically
unobtainable. scouting is the same way. there are things about scouting that
are theoretically obtainable but practically
unobtainable, and realizing that takes some pressure off
because you understand that the process of playing the game
is the most important thing. not attaining a state of perfection in the
game- and this is an important concept because
you- you know if your particular personality is-
is aimed at achievement and perfection and you focus too closely upon that-
it can make you kind of frustrating to be around
and make you less effective as a scouter, and it's a pretty common
frustration for most of us because we know that there is theoretical
perfection in the game out there, but that perfection is practically
unobtainable. and what will help you kind of
deal with that basic cognitive dissonance,
which is really aggravating, is the idea of measurement,
because measurement is part of games. the rules, policies and procedures
set objective metric standards for measurement of the games
and in scouting, yes, there are some objective metric standards for measurement,
but the most important measurements towards achieving our goal,
which is the development of character based on the ideals of scouting,
are individual: where did you begin, how did you proceed
and where did you end up? did you end up ahead of where you began? then we've
succeeded. now that kind of definition of success
can be characterized as creating an excuse for not
having done better. but every measurement that matters
in scouting it's a complicated calculation
of who the scout is and what their background is
and what they're capable of doing, and it's something we'll examine closer as
we go on. so that's my introductory talk about
the foundations of scouting. i'm very interested in hearing your
questions, your ideas, your comments and reflections on it.
you can get in touch with me by going to scoutmastercgcom
and clicking the contact link at the top of the page,
or you can email me at clark at scoutmastercgcom.
it's clark at scoutmastercgcom.
well, thank you for listening to this 361st edition of the scoutmaster podcast.
i've already told you how to be in touch. it's pretty easy to do: go to scoutmastercgcom.
you can also join those who support the blog in the podcast
by becoming a scoutmastercgcom backer or patron, and there are links
at the top of the page at scoutmastercgcom.
i want to just quickly add here that i am not sponsored by or endorsed by the
Boy Scouts of America or any other scouting organization. this is just me.
i have a podcast and i'm trying to help out my fellow scouts,
and all that remains for me to do today is to make sure that we hear from our
founder, Sir Robert Baden-Pell. Sir Robert,
good luck to you and good camping. why? thank you, sir,
until next time, everyone.